d
qu'est ce qui a poussé david stone salue
aujourd'hui on est lundi et vous vous
dites du donc il serait pas un petit peu
habillée comme dimanche avec les mêmes
lumière que dimanche c'est vrai parce
que je fais un peu cette vidéo là
dimanche le lundi c'est le jour du blog
et je vais vous mettre les rushs d'un
bloc 10 et sur un projet qui s'appelle
secrète studio qui est un projet
vraiment la destination des mentalistes
un peu confirmés et des magiciens peut
confirmer on a tourné dans un studio
secret comme son nom l'indiqué faisait
rentrer
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ici en fait je
vais donner une conférence ici qui va
être a priori film et c'est une
conférence à destination des magiciens
des mentalistes on est censé tourner
dans cinq minutes comme vous pouvez voir
tout est bien prêt et ça c'est olivier
ça c'est le fou qui a eu l'idée de faire
ça ce qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'on
viendrait que c'est bien le faire c'est
bien le mot
mais pour l'instant tout est secret donc
c'est normal personne n'est au courant
on va parler de mémoire de calcul de
toutes ces petites choses qu'on aime
bien tellement secret qu'en fait c'est
c'est un entrepôt désaffecté
tu vois le truc faut pas donner
l'adresse faut pas donner l'adresse il
faut pas dire que c'est au 28 rue de la
république à merde
après un retard d'à peu près de deux
heures
j'ai eu des petits soucis techniques et
où la conférence enfin terminé et puis
et puis voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais
à dire plus tôt dans la journée je vous
ai une question sur les réseaux sociaux
répond daisy c'est vraiment important
c'est pour la vidéo de jeudi je veux la
faire en fonction de vos réponses donc
n'hésitez pas à aller voir sur facebook
twitter instagram starch à tout ça je je
je propage la question partout partout
partout partout
j'espère que cela dit a bien commencé
pour vous passé une très bonne semaine à
demain à 17 heures pour le mental blog
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
ciao